all right Andrew's got us in the room of
requirement uh wearing we we kind of
went casual mode on the outfit here
wearing a nice jumper
um and and I think that's a good jumping
off point jumping off point
for uh the personalization of the space
as well not just your character and and
the visuals of your character but
actually this space is a place that you
can make your own
um yeah it was super important to us
that this space really did feel like
um your reflection as a wizard so you
can change the architecture in here
different themes throughout starkly
different themes to really just Hammer
home that this is this is yours oh my
God what this is beautiful we never
expected that to be oh my God
that's the thing is not only can you
change the architecture here but you can
actually conjure little objects uh into
this space as you can see so you can
there's like statues that you can do and
ornaments and tables and rugs and just a
bunch of little things that really flesh
out the space and bring it to life oh my
goodness because like we we had an idea
that those places where you brew stuff
that's where you can change but you can
do all of this where do you even get
this stuff like there's a furniture
store yeah so we call them conjurations
uh and the conjuration recipes can be
purchased at tomes and Scrolls in
hogsmeade but also as you engage in
different types of gameplay throughout
the world you'll be rewarded with
different objects that's so cool and you
change the color you can change the
color you can change the size of it and
you can place it basically anywhere oh
my God it's so tiny it's like her baby
niffler and I love how the the system
too is designed it's not mechanical it's
immersive and so you get the magical
effect of conjuring it in and you're
you're you're actually doing this in the
world as your character but the way
you've Blended like that gameplay with
the immersive uh design of personalizing
God like and I love the animation how it
like appears you know like it's not just
like there it's like it almost like it
operates it is really quite beautiful
and that was the thing is we wanted that
to look really nice because the Magic in
The Wizarding World is everywhere it's
it's physical it's kinetic and it's
whimsical we really wanted to nail that
Whimsy in this space but another thing
that I wanted to discuss is that not
only can you like conjure things and you
can change their their look but you can
do that with the utility objects as well
so you can see that we have planting
pots and potion stations and you could
change the look of those uh as well and
these are the areas where as we had
mentioned previously you'll be growing
your plants you'll be brewing your
potions right right right right right
so while you're also doing these uh like
kind of nurturing based activities this
is also the space where you would bring
your gear Gear to be identified and
geared to have um like rates put on it
which I believe Alan can talk to oh yeah
um I we keep bringing up appearance and
and how it looks and and on like uh in
the game you can look like anything you
want to whenever you want to
um but the player will be finding
different types of gear that we call it
uh as you progress through the game and
essentially we just know that that
clothes and different items in The
Wizarding World can have different
magical properties and as you uh as you
explore and as You Adventure as you
defeat enemies you're going to be
finding different pieces of gear that
have different abilities and that can
help you in your journey and are a major
part of you kind of growing as a wizard
and advancing as a wizard and so it's a
huge list and not all the time uh
whenever whenever you get a new piece of
gear you don't necessarily know exactly
what it does and so there's a station
inside of the room of requirement that
you can conjure it's one of the first
things you conjure uh called an
identification station where you can
actually see that that gear that you're
uncertain about and learn what its
abilities are right yeah that's so cool
and then as the space advances even
further and the space will eventually
grow its own rooms and you're going to
get new recipes you know like like
McKenzie's talking about all these
different things keep expanding and as
it expands eventually you're going to
earn what we see here which is called a
loom and when you set up a loom it's an
ability to essentially customize exactly
which magical properties are on your
gear and take any piece of gear and
adjust its properties and to tweak what
it does and I mentioned earlier that
that you can make anything look like
anything the collection of of cus of
appearances we call it or Cosmetics
we've been referring to it right the
stream those types of things you can use
and you you can apply a look to any
other other look so if you get a piece
of gear you put it on you look like that
but you can change it to look like
whatever you want
that's so cool and like you just you can
just put some ability to this sweater
but then you can just swap yeah that
ability yep and uh appearances you can
edit whenever you want in the gear
screen the loom is specifically about
applying uh traits and and applying uh
larger upgrades that just kind of grant
you greater statistical advantage or
give you really specific abilities that
blend in nicely with where you're trying
to go with your combat fantasy or
talents and things like that interesting
I'm just like I've just seen that
they're just like pump skin fur
mooncuffer where does that come from
yeah and so you'll notice that the
ingredients that are used to add traits
and to upgrade your gear are based
around beasts so this is where we get
into the Beast care section which is
inside this vivario on a bigger space on
the inside idea and so you can see here
we have a couple of bee style we have a
graph horn and a moon calf and a niffler
and a nasal as well so a quite a variety
oh my God he's just like a big puppy
oh my God they're together
oh he's heading them as well but feeding
them too and so once you do those things
that's when they feel safe enough they
can they'll give you their their magical
ingredients so mooncap for
um niffler fur Etc that can then be used
in your in your gear that is like so
like intuitive because like you know
that makes sense because when you touch
the animals you get some fur leftovers
that's so
my God yeah and we really want to hammer
home the fact that this is like a home
that you're making for them so in the
Overland you can find these Beast ends
and rescue these beasties part of doing
so is brushing them and feeding them
food as well and to build that
relationship with with your beef in
addition to be able to care for beasts
you can actually conjure things in this
space as well uh the house the cottage
yeah right and so we have like a lot of
little ornaments in this area and a lot
of them are purely cosmetic but they
look really cool again it's the
personalization of this space oh my
goodness no this is like I'm gonna spend
eight hours just designing this whole
area to personalize this is like cool
it's like you have this little play area
like a personalized fish tank so to say
just for the creatures I love it yeah I
know totally and there's like a
decoration aspect but there's also we
were saying inside uh as well is there's
a utility utility aspect to it too so as
you progress in the game and you're able
to purchase more conjugations you're
able to speed up your process so one of
them for example is the food processor
which
allows for the beasts in the space to
automatically get feed so you don't have
to do it manually and so you're really
building the progression for yourself
here in addition there's also a toy box
where you can play with your beasts
you'll see here yeah so you can there's
a bunch of toys in it and each Beast has
their own favorite toys so as you can
imagine the moon calf really likes the
moon ball or the needle as like a little
cat really likes to chase the yarn ball
all right and they're super cute
oh my God watching them it's so cute
and the big thing we really wanted to
hammer home uh is that the world is a
dangerous place and so by going and
rescuing these beasts and bringing them
back here and caring for them you're
really helping helping them out there's
poachers in the Overland uh who want to
who hunt these Beasts for their material
so instead you're caring for them you're
giving them a home right
corn is just gigantic
but he looks like my dog
oh you could actually name them as well
so like your dog
so getting back into that
personalization you know yeah we didn't
want you to just like throw in oh here's
a here's a graph horn in here like this
can be named whatever Andrew's about to
name them
Bruce
and uh you you can get additional
vivariums correct uh it's a different
kind of
Aesthetics and looks to where you're
keeping your base and caring for them
percussion is a big part of the space as
well so as you progress through the
story you will unlock more
quiet Meadow themed big open bright but
there's other ones say like a swamp that
you might encounter and it's really a
visual effect to and more space for for
your feet oh so it's like those when
we're inside the room requirement
there's like on the left there's that
moon glow from one entrance and then
some Shrubbery going on in the right is
that what you're talking about that's
exactly it ah oh you put trees in here
too oh my goodness yeah
and and another thing with the the Beast
care that I think is is great uh you
know tying back to this same kind of
thing that you did with like the broom
where the broom is not just a method of
travel it's it's actually built in and
integrated into the world in the same
way like Beast care isn't just this this
added element you're not just throwing
it on top there's really this like
narrative and integration to
yeah everything everything so as you
progress through the missions you'll
expand the space
um as you earn resources you'll go into
hogsmeade and and use them to uh unlock
the gameplay here and unlock new
conjurations and different things to
play around with in the open world uh
it's in those different
um in those different environments like
the different combat and conflicts and
Bandit camps and different things like
that that exist in the Overland those
things are what hold recipes that exist
in the loom so all these things have a
way of connecting
um Moonstone that you find out in the
world is the resource that we use to
conjure everything that's found
throughout the world forageables are
used for recipes so really everything's
like a everything's like a cycle and
keeps you coming back but even with the
story that's being told too you know I
think people know who poppy is and and
uh that she has a particular affinity
for beasts yeah I mean I think
everything we're seeing here you know
you're going to be venturing out into
the world uh and and this is just kind
of the tip of the iceberg or even even
of kind of like your interactions with
beasts and that narrative so you know
you're bringing a poppy they're more
they're more uh kind of mysteries to
discover and things to discover around
the world that have to do with her and
that have to do with caring for beasts
and so different characters have their
own have their own stuff uh uh that that
just kind of make this all just kind of
the beginning the beginning of your
journey